étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai récemment eu l'occasion d'assister au mro
Americas à Atlanta et j'ai vu l'une des
choses les plus incroyables que j'ai jamais vues de
ma vie, c'est vrai, ce que vous regardez,
c'est un saut CFM  Moteur 1B
construit entièrement à partir de Legos, il a été construit
par Lufthansa Technic, le moteur lui-même
est construit à 60 de la taille réelle du
moteur et il est composé de plus de 400 000
pièces de Legos, pèse environ 992 livres
pendant très longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le son revient
merci
maintenant je comprends que vous aimez
aussi la guitare
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons que vous ayez sa pancarte
faisons à nouveau America Glam